[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti che ci crediate o no
questo ero io
25 chili fa era il 2013 e stavo
lavorando felicemente presso una squadra
sportiva
a proposito complimenti per lo scudetto
il 6 gennaio ricevetti una telefonata
con una proposta di quelle che non si
possono rifiutare
l'allora presidente del consiglio
professor monti aveva deciso di salire
in politica costituendo una lista civica
e mi fu chiesto di dare una mano sui
temi digitali ci rifletta e un po e poi
disse va bene
e fu così che con le elezioni politiche
del febbraio del 2013 fui eletto in
parlamento alla camera dei deputati e mi
misi al lavoro e cominciai a parlare con
i colleghi di altri partiti e con gli
addetti ai lavori e abbiamo fatto e
lancia questa proposta di un sistema
unico di identità digitale identità
digitale per i tecnici è una cosa molto
chiara molto definita è una parola è un
termine che può determinare delle
incomprensioni con persone non coloni
non informatici e forse se potessi
tornare indietro cambierei questo
termine lo chiamerà il sistema di
autenticazione l'identità in italia
viene data dai genitori viene registrata
che decidono il nome delle dei figli
ci sono delle regole in merito al
cognome delle leggi e poi viene
registrata dal ministero degli interni
ed è quello che dai documenti documenti
sulla base delle quali poi si costruisce
tutto dalla tessera d'abbonamento del
tram
la tessera universitaria della
biblioteca e via dicendo
ecco il sistema di identità digitale si
basa sui allo stesso modo sui documenti
rilasciati dalle autorità del ministero
dell'interno dalla questura carta
d'identità passaporto e costruisce su
questo un sistema di autenticazione
nell'aprile del 2013 si insediò il
governo letta il governo letta il
presidente letta nominò francesco caio
commissario per il digitale e francesco
che amo con se una persona e gli piace
ricordarlo qui andrea rigoni che fu
l'anello di congiunzione diciamo tra i
tecnici e legislativi lavorando
all'interno della task force di
francesco caio e a questa idea di questo
sistema condiviso di autenticazione in
modo tale da poter aumentare la quantità
di servizi digitali e resi al cittadino
e anche di abilitare il fatto che fosse
riconoscibile un indie di una persona ad
esempio per dei contratti in modo certo
e anche per dei fornitori di servizi
privati
a lui si deve il nome speed sistema
pubblico di identità digitale l'anno
successivo il 2014 arrivo l'europa con
il suo regolamento ed as che è un
regolamento di servizi fiduciari c con
con valenza valore circolare in europa
ovvero sono servizi fiduciari che
vengono riconosciuti tra un paese e
l'altro per cui la mia identità speed le
mie credenziali speed possono essere
utilizzate in danimarca in svezia in
francia in portogallo e anche i servizi
di firma digitale e anche insomma tutta
una serie di servizi recapito
certificato qualificato in italia la
nostra pec sono cose che hanno un valore
è riconosciuto in europa e naturalmente
se questo valore riconosciuto ogni
catena è forte quanto il suo anello più
debole per cui tutte le regole devono
essere condivise perché non possiamo
pensare all'interno di questa catena di
avere dei fornitori e meno affidabili
per cui ogni scelta in materia di
evoluzione di questi servizi va
condivisa con i nostri partner europei
adesso faccio un salto indietro di
qualche anno prima che entrasse in
parlamento e questo signore è lawrence
lessig in un intervento alla camera dei
deputati
a lui si deve l'idea dei creative
commons quel sistema che arricchisce il
copyright con delle regole che
consentono la condivisione e riutilizzo
gratuito di opere dell'ingegno
ma lui si deve lui che è un fine
costituzionalista si deve anche un
osservazione molto interessante lui
scrisse un libro molto
tante cose e lui osservò che il codice è
legge così come le leggi ci consentono
non consentono di fare determinate cose
anche il codice ci consente di fare o
non fare determinate cose certe funzioni
delle nostra vita se sono previste dal
programmatore le possiamo fare se non lo
sono non lo possiamo fare se lo erano va
poi il programmatore si gestisce quel
sistema c'è le toglie ecco che noi non
possiamo più farlo vedete alcuni sistemi
autoritari in alcuni paesi autoritari
già oggi il codice viene usato per
determinare chi ha accesso a determinati
servizi oppure no stabiliti da
un'autorità centrale
il codice è legge un'autorità centrale
che decide delle cose e abilità o meno
il fatto che le persone possano fare o
meno determinate cose è un potere
questo signore montesquieu a lui si deve
l'idea moderna che conosciamo dello
stato con la separazione dei poteri
legislativo esecutivo e giudiziario
un sistema di controlli e bilanciamenti
per assicurare che uno stato possa avere
che la democrazia possa funzionare che
non ci possano essere degli abusi del dl
parte dei sistemi autoritari montesquieu
il codice questo nuovo potere dove lo
avrebbe messo l'esercizio di questa la
definizione magari all'interno del
potere legislativo così come definisco
si definiscono le leggi ma la gestione
del software l'operatività sotto
l'autorità del potere esecutivo come
avviene in certi stati autoritari
appunto dove si possano decidere di
togliere alle persone determinati
diritti e facoltà o sotto e magari
arbitrariamente da parte della
dei suoi vertici o sotto il potere
giudiziario che è un potere separato che
vigila sugli altri che li che vigila
sulla sul paese sul sull'esecutivo ecco
probabilmente l'avrebbe posto in qualche
modo sotto il potere esecutivo
questa riflessione fu alla base delle
nostre delle nostre discussioni su come
fare organizzare il sistema federato di
i denti intanto federato e non
centralizzato di identità digitale il
sistema di autenticazione noi prevedendo
che gli identit i provider questi
signori che gestiscono il meccanismo di
autenticazione per inciso ognuno di noi
può avere proprie credenziali da più
fornitori non è mica detto che debba
averli solo da un fornitore può averli
da più fornitori in modo da disaggregare
ulteriormente i propri dati sul soggetto
noi prevedemmo che potesse essere svolto
sia da soggetti pubblici che da soggetti
privati perché iver soggetti privati
perché i soggetti privati come avviene
per la posta elettronica certificata per
la firma digitale un sistema già rodato
e di grande successo
questi fornitori privati sono soggetti a
tutto un insieme di controlli e di
bilanciamenti in primo luogo la
magistratura evidentemente quindi il
sistema giudiziario poi un'autorità
indipendente
il garante della privacy che applica
regole europee
il regolamento per i dati personali e
che stabilisce dei precisi la legge
stabilisce dei precisi limiti su quello
che è il fornitore di autenticazione
l'identity provider può fare cioè nulla
non può fare profilazione non può
conservare tempo indefinito i dati non
può rivenderli grandi garanzie sull'uso
dei nostri
in definitiva l'identity provider i
fornitori di servizi di autenticazione
sa esclusivamente quando accediamo a
all'inps non sa che cosa facciamo con
l'inps però già questo è un dato che non
può essere usato perché se chi vigila e
l'autorità garante per la protezione dei
dati personali
e poi l'agenzia per l'italia digitale
che l'anello europeo di questo insieme
di autorità chiamiamole così
impropriamente dico di sistemi di
controllo e vigilanza che ci sono in
europa per assicurare
che il livello sia omogeneo e che quindi
ci si possa affidare a livello europeo
ecco vedete che questo è un meccanismo
che prevede dei controlli e dei
bilanciamenti dei checks and balances
rispetto all'utilizzo di questo nuovo
piccolo ma importante potere che è il
codice dell'autenticazione digitale in
che linea potrà evolversi in europa si
sta discutendo del fatto di arricchire
questo meccanismo dell'identità digitale
con quello che viene chiamata la self
soverign identity che non vuol dire che
sono io che dichiaro chi sono ma sono io
che custodisco i miei dati
un'attestazione ad esempio il mio
diploma di laurea viene messa in
digitale è conservata all'interno del
mio dispositivo in una sorta di
portafoglio digitale e sono io che
decido a chi esibirla esattamente come
se fosse in modo analogo come se fosse
un documento cartaceo
facciamo un altro salto indietro e
torniamo al 2001
il 2001 è l'anno in cui nasce l'ipod è
l'anno in cui nasce la dsl è l'anno in
cui nasce l'internet per come la
conosciamo un internet fino a quel
momento era una rete magliata composto
da tanti nodi e servizi cooperativi
c'erano tanti fornitori di posta
elettronica ce ne sono molti meno oggi
cos'è successo in questo in questo
periodo nell'evoluzione le norme hanno
consentito la nascita di un modello
alternativo tra il 2008 e il 2010 sono
nati è arrivato facebook in italia è
nato instagram renato twitter e tutti
questi servizi che sono hanno seguito un
modello molto diverso rispetto all'idea
originale di internet distribuita e
federata hanno promosso un modello
consentito dalle norme abilitato dalle
norme un modello centralizzato cioè oggi
internet è sostanzialmente il luogo di
grandi servizi centralizzati gestiti da
grandi monopolisti contro i quali ci
sono un sacco di azioni antitrust e
interventi regolamentari che si
delineano in futuro per cercare di
limitare il loro potere
bene questo è successo in questi i tried
diciamo tra il 2008 quando
sono nati questi servizi ed oggi in una
dozzina d'anni circa 2800 e in questa
dozzina d'anni c'è voluta la
professoressa jukebox ci ha fatto
svegliare e ci ha messo di fronte al
fatto che internet diventata una
macchina per un quello che lei chiama il
capitalismo della sorveglianza
cioè si monetizza il fatto di farsi gli
affari delle altre persone si fanno
denari facendosi gli affari delle altre
persone il capitalismo della
sorveglianza e allora noi ci dobbiamo
chiedere andando in avanti che tipo di
modello vogliamo seguire se vogliamo
seguire un modello distribuito
decentrato come l'idea dell'originaria
dell'inter originale o un modello
centralizzato e questo modello
centralizzato se decidiamo per questo
sotto quale autorità risiede quello che
è successo in questa dozzina d'anni è
successo che il mondo che è sempre stato
aveva questa sua dimensione fisica che
cambiava molto lentamente in qualche
decennio in pochi decenni si è
arricchito di un'interfaccia utente
digitale immateriale che è diventata la
principale interfaccia utente della
dimensione materiale cioè noi oggi
agiamo sul mondo mediati attraverso i
nostri dispositivi
facciamo un salto in avanti e pensiamo
al 2030 cosa succederà nel 2030 questa
cosa sarà ancora di più a livello
europeo
tutto quello che faremo contratti litigi
disdette sarà tutto è svolto in modo
digitale presentazione di documenti
partecipazioni a gare a concorsi tutto
sarà svolto in modo digitale e quale
modello quale paradigma vogliamo
scegliere quello che noi fa avremmo nel
2030 dipenderà dalle scelte che facciamo
oggi e le scelte che facciamo oggi
devono tener presenti in primo luogo che
lo stato non è un'azienda l'obiettivo di
un'azienda è quello di massimizzare il
ritorno degli investitori è orientato
alla pura efficienza l'obiettivo dello
stato è orientato anche alla resilienza
è orientato anche al fatto di garantire
che ci sia la democrazia
che venga mantenuta la democrazia lo
stato non è un'azienda lo stato una cosa
anche diversa perché ha il monopolio
della forza un'azienda non può metterti
in prigione lo stato si e quindi non è
come gli altri soggetti
e anche questo deve essere un criterio
guida quando pensiamo a questo nuovo
potere del codice come lo pensiamo se
federato centralizzato e sotto il
controllo di quale potere dobbiamo
ricordarci sempre che si può entrare in
un sistema autoritario semplicemente
votando ma non è altrettanto facile
uscirne se pensate che questi siano
paure infondate
questo è un tweet di un senatore di una
grande democrazia occidentale twitter
recente in cui dice la democrazia non è
l'obiettivo
la libertà la pace la prosperità lo sono
noi vogliamo che la condizione umana sia
fiorente la democrazia elettiva può
essere una minaccia perché perché votano
delle persone che non sanno cosa il
meglio per loro noi elite sappiamo
questo ragionamento è la base di tanto i
sistemi autoritari
noi sappiamo cosa è giusto per il popolo
e quindi hanno una è un idea rispetto
alla nostra idea di democrazia
abbastanza stridente la democrazia e
questo non è accaduto secoli orsono
accaduto qualche mese fa la democrazia
non dobbiamo dimenticarlo mai
è una cosa fragile fragile e guai a
darla per scontata
nemmeno nei paesi di lunga tradizione
democratica che hanno insegnato queste
cose al mondo
la democrazia è una cosa fragile e
allora va protetta bisogna costruire nei
momenti di luce le salvaguardie
strutturali anche digitali che ci
tutelino nei momenti cupi perché sennò
il rischio è che un giorno ci potremmo
svegliare e trovarci una sorpresa le
scelte che facciamo oggi determineranno
il nostro futuro
facciamo le giuste costruiamo cielo
buono come si diceva il ritorno al
futuro buon 2 giugno e buona festa della
repubblica a tutti